but first we're nearing the end of
another long week for joe biden
and per usual the president is once
again
malfunctioning in public check this out
all right i left the list for the second
one down there okay
hang on thank you
thank you we're okay now esrez 15.
speaker pelosi maxi walters and chewie
garcia
senator i hope
i think i'm kidding i'm not now esther
has 13
disapproval of an equal opportunity
commission rule related to internal
procedures
speaker pelosi bobby scott and
and uh and uh suzanne
bonamicia they get everybody i'm so used
to doing things with bobby he's getting
he's getting worried with chico which
one i better be careful
so given biden's struggles who's in
charge here at the white house
is it ron claim the chief of staff is it
susan rice
it's probably not kamala harris her
tenure as vp has been
a debacle a disaster
according to a new politico report 22
staffers
are now speaking out about the
dysfunction inside the vice president's
office
folks it's only been six months six
months that's
it and they're already complaining
backstabbing disorganization
toxic behavior one harris staffer called
it
a quote abusive environment another said
it was an unhealthy workplace where
people are treated like
you can fill in the blank there folks
and it's not roses by the way
and according to these whistleblowers it
all starts at the top
we're less than six months into this
administration
and it's already not going well and now
president trump appears poised to
potentially
make some major political waves check
this out
let me ask the crowd of everybody here
would you like to see the president
running in in 2024
without giving the answer what the
answer is have you made up your mind
yes
i think you got it right yeah if you
move forward
you know how difficult it is but you
seem ready to
re-engage in in that battle and
when it's not that i want to the country
needs it
we we have to take care of this country
i don't want to is this fun
fighting constantly fighting always i
mean
the country what we've done is so
important
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else